this is Startalk this question comes
from Anthony Edward Stark coming to us
from Twitter and and and I have to say
let me preface his question by saying
this is something that so many people I
believe
want to know and and believe that this
is the case here's what athletes do you
think we humans might be some alien
species brought to Earth from some other
planet if yes how now of course that is
the Prometheus model where we've been
human life was seeded on earth okay so
we were seeded here
liberally though maybe it started on
Mars and came you know there's lots of
rocks flying around the solar system
that that that theory is called
panspermia okay life got started for
instance on Mars a big rocket say that
again now that's the theory is what now
they're damned panspermia that okay that
life my planet or moon just let you know
Dan if you if you notice I did not make
a joke there I should be very proud of
opportunity okay I just I let that go
let it go did you see the restraint yes
answer Leah let's hear more about
panspermia so suppose life got started
on mars that we know that big rocks
smashed into mars occasionally and and
and then rocks go flying all over the
place with Martian rocks and some of
them have come to earth you can go to n
arctica and find these rocks if you find
a black rock on the snow then you see
you can find out that it's got Martian
atmosphere in it so we have rocks from
Mars here on earth that have and maybe
life got started on Mars or some other
place and came here and that's how life
got started on earth we really don't
know where it came from it might have
gotten started on earth probably most
likely it did get started on earth but
we don't know but if we do find life in
our own solar system a really
interesting thing will be is it a
completely different kind of life does
it use different chemicals different
chemistry maybe
kind of DNA different amino acids if
that's if that happens if we find a
different kind of life with a different
chemistry that means that life got two
completely independent starts in our own
solar system owies
the universe is teeming with life Wow
that I mean that's just the prospect of
that is mind-blowing because it means
that throughout the entire galaxies you
could have like an unlimited disparate
amount of life oh if life forms dan is
absolutely correct if we ever find that
a second genesis took place in our solar
system it means the spell has been
broken right and it means that life is
no longer a bug but a feature of the
universe in which we live and that's
that's why you know we're so passionate
about wanting to find out the answer to
this Wow but but anyways exciting so
yeah I will say of course that the
chances what Dan was talking about is
that you could have an impact on a body
like Mars or the earth and have rocks
from it go flying through the solar
system and maybe even end up in the
outer solar system on a moon like Europa
or Enceladus but the further out you go
the less the chances are actually for
that to happen so it's why some of us
really think that in our solar system
Enceladus is probably the best chance
for us actually being into acid ask the
question whether or not life has gotten
started a second time but in our solar
system and it could be where the answer
also could be that the chemistry the
biochemistry is the same maybe that's
the best biochemistry that the universe
has been able to come up with